I make love with ya pada yeah hey i'm
canè i have an awesome mom and you might
have seen her in a few videos in the
past yeah
oh we went to it boring though he won't
make me a cowgirl Oh gingy yes honey
cutter never where'd it one I love her
and apparently so do some of you my
parents are getting older and even
though I have a good relationship with
my mom she's always seen me as her
youngest child because of that I've
never had a super deep conversation with
her so while my parents are still here
and happy and healthy I want to make
sure I get to know them as much as I can
so I looked up a bunch of articles and
questions from different websites and I
compiled a few key questions that I have
personally never asked my mom let's go
plan
okay mom yes welcome hello all right do
you know what we're doing today I don't
know what you're asking I didn't tell my
mom what questions I was gonna ask her
gonna be a surprise for the both of us
what answers I'm gonna get that first
question what happy memory will you
cherish forever
I think 22 I am in love with yeah yeah
we a lot together
please tell me you mean you fell in love
yeah
you might have seen how my mom and dad
react to each other and this is how they
have been my whole life ya say love me
and I fell in love you're 30 why did you
fall in love because we are neighbor
they've been together for 40 years
growing up probably seen my parents
argue maybe three times a year that
really informed a lot of how I view
relationships now there are so many
people that have said the way canes dad
looks at canes mom they definitely make
each other better people what was your
childhood like oh very hot well her
father income for family not Tommy tag
wore mesial mcknight bum bumbum later
how far away was it everywhere yeah how
old were you when the war started no wha
I think they need I didn't usual so
almost your whole early life there was
war Vamsi mom so being born in America
I've always had trouble fully
understanding the scope of what it means
to grow up in a war-torn country only a
few months ago did I sit down with my
dad and ask him a few questions about
how he grew up he casually just
mentioned the fact that he had a sibling
died while at home because the building
was attacked for me at least I grew up
pretty privileged all I had to care
about was school figuring out my passion
and dreams my parents were trying to
figure out how to protect their family
and trying to survive did you go to
school
your few yi not too much my mom was only
able to get elementary middle school
education back in Vietnam a few years
ago my mom finally had a chance to take
classes and go to school I had never
seen my mom with like a light in her eye
as much as when she got to go to
Community College she felt really proud
and I felt really proud of her Mia hey
Michael life I'm not really proud my
brow
America and hold on Kyoya Tom I teach I
know you go Jota young Tom Akana
I'm going to need a maganda I am so
thankful that they made the sacrifice to
come to a country where they didn't know
the language didn't have a community
that they could lean on and they made it
work for their kids
how would your parents describe you they
I don't have time to tell our children
the family need to pick the food bring
the money they're too busy yo grandma a
lot Hilda nobody happiness harmful tale
do you wish she spent more time
no upon me to enjoy herself I Pau you
got some rope soy a ball so long
DJ no et seen no tea no some good job I
think see happy like that I can't even
imagine raising one kid but raising nine
children in Vietnam during the war it
makes sense what my mom was saying that
she just was focused on keeping her kids
alive mom Michael life what is the
hardest decision mama mia hold on don't
go they may take your time I know how to
join how to pack the heart what is your
biggest regret
Naomi Copa de gallo copy will ya my son
top real state motto son yeah you know
I'm not a know how to be up listening
hearing this was probably one of the
saddest things because I know that my
mom would have been a kick-ass real
estate agent have the privilege of
always trying to live my life without
regret that's only possible because
while my parents have given up does make
me sad because she did spend that time
taking care of us at home instead I have
memories of them collecting soda cans
from trash cans when I was younger my
dad working two or three jobs everything
from like restaurant to gardening
delivering pizza mechanic cooled up now
my sister is a real estate agent what
age were you
the most happy like everything is
awesome the children know how to work
how to break up the line
do you feel like that happened already
yeah Casey who told your parents
very proud my amamiya a family tradition
Marty to me Joe my Tony America
Christmas anyone happy trail Dougie go
shopping market everyone happy and they
thinking we clock together and they keep
what you like Christmas because it's
very happy yeah
and Thanksgiving I was almost 100% sure
that my mom was gonna save Chinese New
Year in this interview I've learned how
much my mom that I use just happiness
even the expression of happiness we do
have epic Christmas and Thanksgiving
family parties where we all go to my
grandma's place everyone brings a giant
dish anywhere from like egg rolls and
noodles to like KFC chicken we just eat
and chat and my aunts would be cutting
coupons for the next day's discount what
would make you happy now oh sorry mommy
Oh tidy maybe we're not already I think
that any win it is okay but not too much
though my Macquarie it not for real hi
how much is it to retire we don't know
yet I've never actually seen her get a
lottery ticket but who doesn't want the
option to retire I think what I didn't
realize was how much they wanted to and
are waiting to retire what do you want
to do after retirement
nothing yet keep empty because we are
thinking about energy thinking about
healthy just what's in front
we don't come LAN and our line no come
Linh like what do you want to do maybe
Nikki retire so I wanna go like Davos
so you want to travel that will make you
happy I don't know yet but all the life
just working on the line right now we I
want to feel because the children and we
one know how to take care like you know
mom that's very sad I talk to children
and they will go trouble anyway because
right now
nito salary but your mom and not upset
because your mom know that thing happen
avaylo I didn't realize how much my mom
hesitated to plan future enjoyment
experiences I think she's just not used
to planning that for herself
one small moment that I remember when I
was younger my mom made me this dish
with rice and meat and veggies I ate it
and I was full and it was good I thought
my mom would just make more for herself
but instead she took my leftover rice
and poured tea into it and ate that as
an adult looking back I realized that my
dad was working as a pizza delivery man
at the time our family was probably
struggling financially and my parents
just always shielded me from it my you
yo time beta K yeah Michael far painted
it height a my Vicky Kia what a keen
[ __ ] if I could bloom what a happy very
easy make happy ma plan kotka 3 ly
dragon and light a total I feel happy
sometime I worked a total also PU I
won't hurt you when I was younger she
used to have plants and point them out
and be like hey look at my plants that I
true and I'd be like oh cool now as an
adult I realized how hard it is to take
care of a living plant now going home
seeing my mom make these cool animal
configurations I'm like how do you even
do the Hat mom
like talking huh under Bhutan they have
them out here yellow see ya have four
feet and one tail happy very easy not
not trying to want to technique when
they take that everything around
hepner happy you look your mom play
anywhere it hep-lock
something far away if I were you how you
can you can claw every day every time we
thank you that mean happy down far away
cannot care and if you cannot care you
feel oh I've said boring around and we
everything easy to enjoy and feel happy
see but but your mom not upset so you
want to travel that will make me happy
Japan and China we're in China anyway
have you been to China not yet have you
not been to China ah you've never been
to China yeah that's so weird that
you're Chinese and you've never been to
China it has literally never occurred to
me that my mom who is mostly Chinese I'm
93 percent Chinese my mom has never been
to China anywhere I want to vote awful
if that's something that she wants I
need to take her she definitely deserves
it young my my advice now wait Tom help
schedule all we go outside just thinking
healthy meditation no look at the back
yep go on go on
I feel like I have a lot to show my
parents now that's outside of what
they're used to of just were and I'm
looking forward to doing that with my
mom and my dad I owe everything to her
and she deserves it okay say bye bye
when you say more luck mom letter
[Music]
do you thing and they wanting the time
to listen like that's good I have no
idea we'll see